The joe rogan experience that happens.
I mean,
I,
I'm convinced of certain things and then I find out I'm completely wrong.
You know,
it does happen.
I told you that you better back off the ghost.
Um,
I used to believe a great deal.
I still pretty much believe pretty much,
I think basically this is my entire philosophy on all weirdnesses okay.
If you look back 500 years to what they knew scientifically,
then it's superstitious.
It's magic.
It's ridiculous,
it's ignorant,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I believe that that's exactly what we are now to 500 years in the future.
So I don't consider it paranormal.
I consider it future science goes for future science,
go surf future science aliens or future science.
It's all future science.
And I'm down for that.
I'm ready to party with the future science and I'm ready for that.
Except that my problem is the people that tell ghost stories or those fucking go
shows because they're so bad,
they're so faked.
There are so painfully faked.
I really believed it for a while.
Like I really absolutely bought into it.
Hook,
line and sinker.
It's like they're watching the little there,
the,
there's all different kinds of ghosts.
Like the ones that look like,
um,
he walks or not your walks,
which are the ones that are the jet,
the first movie star wars and they like were there little robes and they were
busy.
They were like,
oh,
you know the first ones,
they're like,
we're selling robots.
I don't know.
They didn't really have faces.
They just had like cloaks the robot sellers.
Well apparently there are ghosts that are little cloak creatures and they scare
the crap out of me.
The cloak ones do,
they move fast and I don't understand what they're doing here like,
but I mean you can explain demons.
You can explain demons.
If you think about like dog ghosts or wolf ghosts or lion ghosts,
that's a demon.
Could be.
They growl.
They have like weird eyes.
They're hostile.
They scratch you animal.
So you,
you have a real belief in ghosts.
Yeah.
Not 100% but
I bump into them sometimes they think and I don't see them,
but I feel them and hear them and that like I know go ahead.
A little smile.
That little smile.
That's why not we're talking about it cause we're on the weirdness podcasts but
like I don't talk about it cause it just doesn't get a good response
when you bought,
I believe you,
you don't seem like a liar by any stretch of the imagination,
but I have a huge imagination.
I could very easily be tricking myself into something.
What do you feel?
What happens?
I just bump into that and be like,
they just,
if you walk into a room,
I mean it happens maybe once a year and you walk into a room,
you walk somewhere or something's going on and you just feel it and it's a very,
very strong and you,
I just,
I talked to them.
I just say like mostly hotel rooms.
Let's just say if I'm in a hotel room on tour and I led their move,
if I don't like it or I'll just say alone in that room,
I'll be like,
hi.
Okay,
I'm playing a show and so I'm only here for two days,
but I really need to get some sleep.
Um,
you can come to this.
I tell them they can come to the show if they want.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
I'm like,
this is what I do for a living,
and I try to like hear and think what they do for a living.
I would be psyched if I was a ghost and I fell on you.
I'm like,
this chick's cools
that.
Don't you want to scare?
Let her sleep,
man.
Let her sleep.
Fuck down.
I got the pots and pans ready to make a racket.
Let her sleep.
She's cool.
Let's go to the show.
I put them on my guest list was like,
you've got a plus one.
That was nice.
You don't have to reserve a seat.
Obviously you have an active imagination and do you think that maybe your mind
fucking yourself at the time?
Like when you're saying,
well you're talking out loud,
are you doing it because it's comforting because you enjoy it?
Probably,
but,
but if you asked me on a lie detector test whether I think I really encountered
something,
I'd say yes for sure.
I mean there's been enough experiences in my life that it just seems like just
part of future science.
There's a guy named Rupert Sheldrick,
he's a scientist and he believes that things have memory.
He thinks that everything has memory things.
That's why people don't want to live in haunted houses.
You know?
Don't want to live in a house where someone died.
He thinks that objects have memory.
They can't express it,
but that they have it.
I agree with that.
It might be,
we're like,
we haven't,
I think it's less the object retaining it.
I mean it must be retaining something.
I think it's more our psychic ability to perceive the past.
Yeah,
that's what I think.
I think it's more like you see the chair and then you can psychically feel what
happened in that chair.
I'm not really sure how to like,
you're not seeing the chair imbued with some aura.
You're actually looking into the past.
Yeah,
that's what I think cause I've had dreams that were like prefiguring figuring,
I think you can dream if something's impactful enough.
I think you can dream.
Okay.
Let's say something really bad happens to you.
Imagine something horrible.
Okay,
I dunno,
this studio explodes.
Okay.
A couple months maybe before then you might have a dream.
Well,
let's just say something goes really,
really wrong or bad.
Nothing traumatic.
You might be able to have a dream ahead of time.
That would be how you would synthesize that traumatic experience.
Just as if it had happened before and you were dreaming after the fact before
you've had that happen.
I have,
would you,
how it happened with,
um,
I'm saving that for my book.
Is that okay?
Yeah.
That's okay.
But it was a very powerful,
very absolutely fuck off.
Absolutely.
Absolutely good.
But it was very convincing to me and hard to explain any other way.
Have you ever had any other sort of psychic premonition?
Yes.
Really?
Do you remember the last big fire we had in la when it was like encroaching
recently?
Yeah,
that one.
Um,
the night before that fire I was out walking with my son again.
My son,
he's like all over this podcast.
I don't know why,
because he barely speaks to me at the moment.
And he's like,
yeah,
fine,
good talk to you later.
Um,
and I just felt incredibly uneasy and he suffered from asthma when he was young
and really badly.
So when it would be when there was a lot of particulate matter in the air,
or if it was just bad air conditions,
I would tend to be very worried about him and keep him home or informed the
teachers or whatever it was.
It just,
he get really bad asthma attacks.
And so I have a predisposition to be on the alert,
but this is the night before no fire had started yet and I just was very
anxious,
very anxious,
and I couldn't settle down and I couldn't think for months.
I hadn't been like that.
I mean,
and I said to him,
I'm like,
I don't know what it is,
but I feel kind of unsafe if something happens tomorrow you have to like,
you have to be my witness that I've sensed something was coming.
Now you probably think I'm this horrible mother,
I never do this.
It happens.
Like I think I've said that to him twice in our entire life and
I forgot about it the next day.
I forgot about,
I didn't think about it at all until,
you know,
we were socked in and this sort of Brown muck as we are.
And like the sun became the eye of Sauron and ever,
you know,
everyone's like freaking out and we're looking at all these images and I was so
distracted by all these images that I completely forgot my sense the night
before and what I think that was until I remembered it.
Then I called up and I'm like,
ah.
And I think it's more like,
I don't know something's coming,
but I have maybe time,
maybe the envelope with time is a little bit more mushy than we think.
Maybe we perceive time is very orderly and very linear,
but maybe it's really not.
And it could be pushing back like the experience.
And maybe I had the experience before I perceive the experience or I don't know
what that is,
but that happens to me a lot.
I've heard people describe,
nobody likes hearing about it.
By the way,
I never talk about this stuff in my real life because nobody likes.
What do you mean it makes people uncomfortable and they look at you funny.
So I just never talk about it except for on the podcast.
Why would it make them uncomfortable?
It just does.
I'm fascinated by that because I don't experience it and I've never,
I've never had a premonition
that came true,
but I do have a really good ability to know if someone's crazy.
I'm really good at that.
Apparently.
I'm not.
No,
you're not crazy.
I mean,
I don't know if someone's don't even on a lot of crazy people blind spot.
That's where you can pick out fires in the dos days,
but you can't pick out nuts.
Yeah.
I don't have any psychic ability though.
I've just,
I think I just know though.
Mm.
Uh,
don't,
if you can tell if someone's crazy or not,
you might have some,
I mean,
you might have some perception.
I think it's pattern recognition and data chunking.
Oh,
see I've met so many people.
Then when I see things that are off little things that are off and you probe,
like you're talking a little,
things are off more and you're like,
you see the looking into the eyes,
you see calculations,
you're like,
okay,
something's going on here.
This is not a,
it's not a normal person.
There's a person putting on a normal mask.
Like there's something off here.
It just smells,
smells fishy,
you know?
I just think it's that.
I just think if we have them as guests,
I mean are they are sitting across from me?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Bat Shit crazy.
What do you do?
I've had people on what I was sure they were pilled up for sure.
I'm like talking to him like this motherfucker's Adderall to the gills.
Like when their Adderall,
there's talking,
there's just something about the way the talk to not really cut least fair.
It's not,
that's not what it's about.
It's not about me.
It's about the future.
It's about children.
It's about that society.
What I'm trying to do is be,
I'm an entrepreneur.
I'm going to build businesses.
They just start,
they just info wars.
Alex Jones,
we got him high and drunk and he was talking about on the show.
Is that what goes down here?
And I like,
oh,
look at this.
I am in a den of inequity Ellis.
Yes.
We've got some,
like that's some Sutton.
That's what is that?
Yeah.